at first glance fortnite might just seem
like a typical video game
but what if i told you that it's
actually just one small piece
of a 30 billion dollar empire that is
set to change
gaming forever fortnite is one of the
most profitable games ever made but the
company behind the game is just getting
started
epic games spent nearly 30 years laying
the groundwork that would allow them to
create the most fun
and most profitable games in the world
instead of simply making a great game
epic has built a network of businesses
that virtually guarantee
continued growth for the company
regardless of what game is most popular
at the moment
tim sweeney is the founder of epic games
and he's been methodically planning to
take over the gaming world
for decades now but you probably don't
know much about him
that's because he intentionally keeps a
very low profile
and is extremely focused on his vision
for the future of gaming
despite being a billionaire he doesn't
spend time partying on fancy yachts
or hanging out with celebrities he's on
a mission to change the world of gaming
forever and fundamentally alter the way
humans interact with each other his
ultimate goal is to create a
fully immersive metaverse like the one
seen in ready player one
and he's already on the right track he's
building all of the fundamental
infrastructure that will be required to
power something like the oasis
and it's starting to scare big tech
companies apple and epic are battling it
out in the courts
but in order to understand what's really
going on here and why tim
is willing to risk everything in order
to take on big tech we have to
understand
tim as a person and drill into what
motivates him
tim has developed some very unique
skills and discovered an incredible
business model in the process
his strategy has completely set epic
apart from the competition
and is truly one of the most interesting
technology stories of the past
30 years tim sweeney was born in potomac
maryland in 1970
and developed a love of computers and
engineering at a young age
he spent his free time disassembling
lawn mowers and playing atari games
but computers weren't exactly widely
available at that time
fortunately for tim he was lucky enough
to be born into a family that had access
to cutting-edge technology see his dad
worked at the department of defense
where his job was to create military
maps as part of the intelligence unit
that meant that his dad had access to
the best computers available at the time
and could see firsthand the impact the
technology was going to have on the
world
additionally tim had a brother who was
10 years older than him who worked in
the computer industry
and helped introduce tim to programming
when he was just 11 years old
when tim saw the flexibility of his
brother's ibm computers
he was immediately hooked he was a
natural programmer and started
dedicating all of his free time to
learning about computers
tim's brother steve clearly recognized
the raw programming talent tim possessed
so he bought him an apple too tim
immediately started building software
for the apple ii
and because his dad was connected to the
dod tim was able to access
basic internet forums to ask questions
about problems that he ran into
at that time the internet was extremely
small you literally had to either work
at a major university
or for the government directly to get
access so tim was extremely lucky to
connect with these experts directly
there are plenty of people with innate
programming skills but that alone
isn't enough to become a successful
entrepreneur you have to understand
business
and develop an intuition for what your
best opportunity is at any given time
tim started developing his business
skills while still in high school he was
working a summer job at a hardware store
and realized that the only way for him
to make more money
was to work more hours at the store so
he quit that job and set up a lawn
mowing business where he could make five
times as much money by setting his own
prices and using a tractor to get jobs
done
faster this idea of always seeking out
the highest leverage opportunity
is at the core of most entrepreneurship
philosophy create a system that makes
money
so that your income no longer requires
your direct input
tim realized this while still in high
school so when he got to college he was
in a prime position to start working on
the most scalable business of all
software development he went to the
university of maryland to study
engineering
and wasn't a particularly great student
he spent most of his time working on
computers and the only courses he really
enjoyed were related to math and physics
which will play a big role later on in
this story he needed to make money while
in college but wanted to build his
computer skills at the same time
so he started a company called potomac
computer systems
at that time he hadn't built a product
yet he was just consulting for small
businesses to make sure that they had
usable computer systems
his new business made enough money to
pay for an ibm 286
which was a big step up in terms of
computing power even though tim enjoyed
programming on the apple ii
more businesses used ibm computers at
the time so that's where the real money
could be made
writing software was extremely
cumbersome and nearly every business
needed custom software to run
efficiently this was before aws
before github and even before basic text
editors existed like vim or emacs
so tim set out to create a text editor
that could speed up software development
but as he was building the text editor
he realized that he could build a simple
video game using the same tools
so he pivoted and launched a game called
zzt
in past videos i've talked about how
tools like discord and slack
grew out of failed attempts to make
games and this is kind of the opposite
scenario
tim wanted to create a tool and wound up
making a game and the game did well
at least given how small the pc gaming
market was at the time
this was 1991 after all interestingly
the shareware distribution model that
tim
used to sell zzt was remarkably similar
to what epic would use to sell fortnite
over 25 years later
he gave the basic version away for free
and then had customers who liked the
game
pay for extra features additionally the
user could edit the game themselves
so anyone who installed zzt could create
their own levels
much like fortnite creator mode which
we'll get to in a minute with zzt
selling well
tim realized that he should focus on
game development and put aside the
consulting work he was doing before
so he changed the name of the company to
epic mega games he was still
distributing zzt as shareware
which meant he had to personally mail
physical copies of the game to customers
but he would keep a hundred percent of
the revenue he generated
most game developers focus on making
their games as good as possible
and then partnering with a publisher
like sony microsoft or nintendo
to actually push their game out to the
public game publishing was still in its
infancy though
and the allure of keeping a hundred
percent of the profits for epic was too
good to pass up
so tim decided to grow his team and
publish more games directly to customers
even though he was still in college tim
hired several key people to help him
develop his next game
which would be a 2d side-scrolling game
called jill of the jungle this game
looks extremely simple nowadays but at
the time it was cutting edge
in order to make and sell this game tim
hired cliff lezinski
who was just 17 years old at the time
and mark rain
who had been working at id software
making games like doom
when people think of doom today they
usually think of the 2016 version for
xbox one and ps4
but back in 1993 doom was released for
ms-dos
computers and looks extremely simple now
but doom was revolutionary at the time
selling millions of copies and
introducing the world to 3d video games
that could be played on a home computer
for the first time
ever in many ways doom was just as big
of a cultural moment as fortnite
completely dominating the conversation
around pc gaming for years
and inspiring tons of game developers to
make their own 3d shooters
tim wanted epic to get in on the action
and make a 3d game like doom
but that wouldn't be easy rendering 3d
levels on basic home computing hardware
required some really complicated game
programming
that only id software had figured out at
the time but tim saw this as an
opportunity
he recognized that anyone who wanted to
make a modern video game
would need to spend countless hours
building the low-level rendering
technology to actually get the game to
work
all of this had to be done before they
could actually create levels integrate a
story or particular game mechanics that
gamers would actually care about
so tim set out to solve this problem for
the entire industry
epic would focus on developing two
pieces of software the first would be a
game called
unreal that would compete directly with
doom but the second would be a game
engine that would allow
any game developer to make their own 3d
game without needing to do all that
low-level programming
this product was called unreal engine
and it's still the core of epic's
business model today
unreal became a popular game soon after
launch but
all the marketing and promotion that tim
did around the game
really served to attract developers to
unreal engine the video game industry
was really starting to take off in the
late 90s and developers wanted to focus
on quickly releasing games without
building an entire game engine every
time they created a new title
unreal engine solved this problem
perfectly and went on to power games
like deus ex
bioshock and splinter cell this was a
huge win for tim sweeney and the entire
epic team
but getting developers to make games
with unreal engine was just the
beginning
they weren't just speeding up
development they were actually unlocking
new markets for game developers see
by the mid 2000s the gaming market had
fragmented
gaming consoles had taken off but there
wasn't a clear winner the playstation
and xbox both had significant market
share
and developers wanted everyone to play
their games regardless of what hardware
they had
by building their games on top of unreal
engine developers could release
playstation
xbox and pc versions of their games
without much extra work
epic was making it easier for developers
to launch bigger games and to make more
money
so these developers were happy to pay
epic a small revenue share in exchange
for use of unreal engine but tim wanted
to make sure that unreal engine would
always be the go-to platform for
developing games
and there was a new generation of gaming
hardware coming out
in 2005 microsoft was going to release
the xbox 360.
and tim knew that if epic could create a
flagship game that everyone played
it would draw even more developers to
unreal engine so epic made gears of war
and it was huge
this game showcased everything that
these next generation consoles could do
and highlighted the power of unreal
engine gears of war featured a bunch of
new mechanics that were only possible
because so much of the heavy lifting was
done by epic's new unreal engine 3.
major franchises like borderlands and
mass effect
used this new version to sell millions
of games and win dozens of awards
with unreal engine growing relentlessly
tim decided to take
outside investment for the first time in
epic's history in 2012 he sold 40
percent of his company to 10 cent for
330 million dollars
this new capital allowed tim to refocus
epic on what really mattered for
long-term growth epic sold gears of war
to microsoft and doubled down on unreal
engine
tim's vision for unreal engine expanded
to meet the needs of all modern
developers the game engine that only
helped with rendering and game
interactions wasn't enough anymore
increasingly games were played online
integrated with payment processors
and needed distribution so epic would
expand to offer
all of that all for the low price of
just a five percent royalty
but 330 million dollars is a lot of
money
and it's natural for any company that
gets a huge cash
influx like that to want to expand even
further
so epic planned out a slew of new games
first they started working on a new
unreal tournament game
but they also wanted to compete with
league of legends so they built a game
called paragon to compete in the
multiplayer online battleground space
minecraft had also recently become very
popular which motivated epic to release
a game that merged
building mechanics with tower defense
they called that game fortnite but the
first version didn't look anything like
the version that's popular now
but in 2017 everything changed for epic
all three of those games got stuck
in development and couldn't really find
a strong audience
there were small beta tests but nothing
really caught on
but then playerunknown's battlegrounds
came out and it was a huge hit
the general idea of a battle royale had
been around for a while
but pubg was the first game to really
bring the concept into the mainstream
with unreal tournament paragon and
fortnite all struggling
tim decided to pivot the company to
focus on battle royale so the unreal
tournament team took what the fortnite
team had built
and focused on building an online battle
royale mode for that game
they sprinted hard to get fortnite
battle royale out into the world
and they released it in september of
2017 just six months
after pubg was released the game was a
massive success
and got 10 million active players within
just two weeks
there were a few key reasons why
fortnite was so successful
and they all built upon the work tim had
done at epic over the previous 25 years
first fortnite was immediately
cross-platform which was only possible
because of all the resources epic had
poured into making unreal engine
platform independent from day one second
fortnite was far less buggy than the
competition
since the epic team knew the unreal
engine code base inside and out
they were able to make sure that the
game could run reliably without issues
on all kinds of devices
even older pcs pubg is actually built on
unreal engine as well
but their team didn't have the resources
or experience to utilize the engine to
its full potential
lastly fortnite was free to play which
has been tim's go-to business model
since he released his first game
ever epic had an entire internal team
dedicated to online services to help
with things like scaling servers
and offering micro transactions even
though they didn't charge for fortnite
up front
epic still made more than 9 billion in
its first two years
incredible but fortnite is just one game
and tim has seen gamers move from one
trend to another really quickly before
the gears of war sequels were never as
profitable as the first game
and betting all of epic on fortnite
staying popular was simply too risky
so he focused on further diversification
since millions of people had already
installed fortnite
he made the decision to convert the
fortnight launcher into a store where
you could buy
all sorts of games valve's steam
platform has been the dominant pc game
distributor for years
but they take a 30 cut of revenue from
game developers
epic majorly undercut valve charging
just 12
which was a huge incentive to start
selling on the epic game store
these royalty fees are a big point of
contention in many parts of epic's
business now
recently they've been trying to get
around apple's 30
in-app purchase fee by allowing
customers to pay with credit cards
directly
instead of going through apple this
violates the app store policies
and has led to a massive lawsuit between
apple and epic games which is still
going on as of june 2021
it's easy to cynically look at this
battle between two tech companies worth
billions of dollars
and assume that they each just want to
make more money and that's not entirely
wrong
but tim sweeney does have a very
specific vision for epic's future that
benefits
from an open internet with low
interchange fees
see tim wants to create a metaverse
where players can take content that they
purchased in fortnite
and bring it into minecraft and vice
versa but that's just the start
increasingly fortnite isn't just about
competition
it's become a place to hang out and
socialize build things with your friends
and see concerts as these games become
more immersive
they start to behave more like social
networks than traditional single-player
games
tim thinks that the future of human
interaction will take place in a virtual
space
powered by unreal engine simply put
being beholden to apple or google
will make it significantly harder to
scale as quickly as he would like
tim has been working on epic for 30
years now and in some ways
he's just beginning his journey the
company has expanded significantly with
four key business lines built around
unreal engine fortnite brings in money
directly and serves as the perfect
showcase for what's possible with unreal
engine
epic online services helps new
multiplayer games scale when they start
growing and need more servers
the epic game store now lets them
distribute not only their new games
but also games from other developers and
epic also has their own studio and
publisher for building and releasing
new games this flywheel is incredibly
powerful
because all of the business lines feed
into one another epic can use the
profits from fortnite to help grow their
game store
and then use profits from the game store
to develop new games
the experience they get from building
fortnite informs how they think about
the next version of unreal engine and so
on
it's a virtuous cycle that helps keep
the company growing indefinitely and
that's awesome
if you want to chat about startups just
leave me a comment below or dm me on
twitter
and please check out this recommended
video the youtube algorithm thinks that
you'll really like it